All right. So, we're going to do another
episode today of AI that works with
myself and
Dexter. And last week, we talked about
how to do classification with a thousand
plus classes. And this week, we want to
talk about something I thought was
really relevant, especially with all the
new models coming out recently. Uh,
Llama 4 came out, a few other approaches
came out. And the things that we want to
spend the most time on is how do these
reasoning models actually help us? Do
they help us? Is there an advantage to
using them? Is there an advantage to not
using them? Um, could we leverage some
of the reasoning capabilities in
existing models without using a
reasoning model? Um, and with that,
let's go off and start talking about
some of the stuff. But as we always say,
it's really hard to go and have a
conversation about these techniques that
seem so
abstract without actually a concrete
example. So, Dex here has put together a
really, really good example. uh that I
think is going to be helpful and
somewhat um good grounding for all of us
to talk about. So we're going to talk
about the example first and then dive
into the reasoning
capabilities. You want to take it away
next? Yeah, let's do it. Um so we have
built um really quickly there is a
public neo forj database for movie
recommendations. So this is just a
public data set. Anyone can plug into
it. It's kind of got like public
username and password. And we've just
built a small little AI agent that can
answer questions about movies. And it's
using agentic tool calling to generate
cipher queries to query against the
database for and cipher is the um name
of the SQLish dialect that they use. So
I can ask this thing something like hey
who's in point
break and we see it gets back and it
runs this query and then you can see
kind of what came back from the database
and it gives you the main actors and so
you can ask it even more complex queries
like what else are they in
um and it gets this very
long pile of JSON.
Um, one of the challenges with this is,
uh, you'll notice, uh, it's just not
that smart in certain cases. Uh, so if I
say who's in the matrix,
um, it's going to run this query and
it's going to get it wrong and it's just
going to keep trying over and over again
until it breaks. Um, but I can come back
here and say like who's in matrix the
and then eventually it'll figure it out
and get the right title. Um, so there's
some interesting things around like
giving it correct like directions and
instructions to follow that I think
we're I think we're using 40 mini right
now. Um, but we'll get into kind of some
of the interesting challenges uh with
how to how to get this thing to do. So
for like writing SQL, writing code, and
other types of tasks that like reasoning
models tend to be much better at. Um,
we'll look at kind of hey, let's drop in
a reasoning model and and see how how
powerful this is. And then we'll uh dig
into some techniques for hey, how can
you use smaller models or non-reasoning
models and uh build your own reasoning
pipeline um and kind of what's happening
under the hood there. So the code for
this is in the repo. Um we'll add some
more outlines and stuff to this as we
go. Um but like five, what do you want
to do? You want to jump into like the
architecture of just what's going on in
the inside? Yeah, I think let's just
grab a whiteboard and just really
quickly outline the code that we have
today. Once we have the code that we
have today um and then we can go ahead
and kind of go from here and uh uh talk
about the reasoning structure. Yeah,
cool. So, um I think the core of this is
just the chat loop.
[Music]
Um so, uh essentially what we've got
here is we've got this big for loop. Um
I'm actually going to draw this out. So,
a message comes in from the front end,
from the
user. Um, and uh, Vibob, I also sent you
I I just shot you a link to this
whiteboard as well.
Um, and we basically going to pass that
into our prompt um, that we called chat
with
graph. Um, so you can see that is
uh, as you may expect a BAML function.
Um, actually, let me just pull up the
actual
code. Um,
wonderful. Okay, cool. So, um, we're
basically asking it, hey, try to help
the user out. We give it the schema of
the database which is
um a big file that looks like this that
just describes the different nodes in
the graph. Um, and then for each
message, we put that in. And then we put
in a system message that basically asks
it to output things in a specific
format. And our response is either going
to be a, you know, string, hey, here's
your answer um, action reply, or
um, it's going to be a graph query where
it's going to tell us what query it
wants to run. So, those are the two
options. And we're basically going to
ask the model to output one of those two
things. If it outputs a graph query um
we will we will go run that tool. Um so
let's say it outputs you
know query
graph then we actually go connect to the
neo forj database
uh and then we add to what we call the
working context here. Thank
you. Right. So it starts with the user
message and
then we will append to the working
context query graph with actually like
the the cipher that it uh
selected and then we add the neo forj
result neo forj result
um including if there was an error there
or something like that.
Um, and then we basically pass that back
into the LLM and it may decide, oh, if
there's an error or it didn't get any
results, um, we saw in the matrix
example, it just kept trying the same
thing again as 40in is want to do. So,
it may loop back through this way or it
may at some point realize, okay, cool.
I'm done calling tools and I want to
just
reply. And then at that point, we kind
of exit out and send that reply back to
the user. And while these are happening,
we're also streaming those back into the
uh into the kind of context window. You
got it. I'm just trying to make a curved
arm line really fast here. I got
you like that. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Yeah.
Cool. Uh does that make sense?
Questions?
Um I'll just recap really fast um on
this really fast. Um, so the idea is
basically that if an LLM is going to go
reply to something, we want to be able
to iterate on iterably over time in this
sort of approach as what Dex showed. And
if we can't iterate on it, then the
problem is we rely on the model to be
perfectly correct. So the front end
really doesn't care about any of these
things. And the reason that the code
that you see is a little bit more
complicated is because what we're
actually doing under the hood is every
single time we add something to the
working context, we're also streaming an
event out to the front
end, letting it know what we're doing to
the working context. So the user doesn't
actually see an opaque block until we
reply. The user is actually seeing the
the working context as it's happening.
And there's interesting things that we
can do in the front end if we wanted to,
which is once the front end is actually
done, we could technically just delete
the working context and only show the
reply. So, so the user doesn't have to
know that it can see like it's an in
progress training. That's a front end
only query that we could like we could
hide. Go ahead. So, we did like who's in
uh who's got a good movie.
Um, finding Nemo. That's
great. I just thought about it.
Um um yeah so like our working context
is this query and the response and then
here's our final answer and I think the
implementation right is that actually
even when I ask another question this
gets cleared out of the context window
right the steps and we only just see the
messages that have happened right
exactly
so the idea is that over time the chat
doesn't need to preserve all the cipher
queries that I have it just kind of
needs to preserve the answer
um so like on the X chat, we still send
the whole contacts window, but we
actually clear these things out. And so
you just have the reply and then the
user message. And then as we're building
up the continued working context, it may
have a bunch of queries here until we
get to the next reply and then these get
crossed out again. Exactly. You nailed
it, Dex. So can I ask a quick question
about that?
So I've been doing similar queries with
uh Neo4j and GraphQL as well. Is there
any advantage keeping the context around
to help correct it? So I found like
sometimes you can't get that first shot
of a query. You prompt it and then it
gets the right one. Have you have you
noticed that pattern? So here's what we
actually do under the hood. So whenever
this Neo4j result comes, this Neo4j
result could be either green because it
actually solved it or it could be red
because it doesn't have the answer. If
it's red, we literally what we really do
is like if this sorry I'll I'll write
this as an error. What we really inject
is something that looks like this.
Oops. An error happened.
You could imagine injecting something
like this where you just say oops an
error happened add it to the context and
now send it back to the model and the
model now generates a new query which we
then get a new neoforj call oops which
we get a new neoforj call and if it's
another error then we keep on adding it
um but if it's not an error it's
actually a result then we add the result
and then we ask the model to go again
but anytime it's not an error what we do
is we actually delete all the previous
queries and all the previous context and
just add it in like this.
Gotcha. Okay, that makes sense. And that
that error as you called it, there's
obviously like a a UI a user could
interject and say, "Hey, you got it
wrong." And that gives us this
opportunity to develop that again,
right? Well, we actually just let the
model know that the errors happen like
Neo4j is telling us the citra query is
wrong. But I think this gets in Yeah,
sorry. I think this gets into um kind of
your point on the last episode as well,
Vibb, which was basically like you can
build whatever you want. And if you have
things structured like this and you have
each step and you have control over it,
then yes, you could build something of
like, oh, when we have two errors in a
row, don't send it back to the model.
Actually send it to the user, but keep
those errors around and send a
deterministic message to the user of
like, hey, we've got two errors, like
what do you want to do about it? And
then append that rather, you know what I
mean?
Yeah. just I mean I guess there's
there's two forms of error, right?
There's the it created an invalid query.
The other form is it got the query
wrong. Um quite complex queries like you
know um give me all the people who did
this who are also starring in that who
are friends with this. Um I find those
queries can break down they break down
slower in cipher than GraphQL. Um, yeah.
But then a really easy thing you can do
is like me and Dex talked about how you
could delete the user messages and then
add in a and we what we do is like we
basically just delete the user message
and we only add in the reply. You could
say an if statement that says if the
query is more than 5,000 characters then
include
it in the context window. It's a choice.
Yeah. like the way you build the context
for the user is really a choice of what
you do.
And if you go back to the UI dance,
yeah, you could even do this in a
different way where you could actually
put checkboxes into your UI that says
like should the should the model
preserve this into the context or not.
So you could even make it user driven
about whether or not the queries are
passed in. It's really turn your users
into context engineers. Yeah, exactly.
turning your users into context
engineers along the way so they can make
an educated decision. You can have good
defaults like very long queries get
added in very simple queries
don't. Does that make sense u?
Yeah definitely that's a that's a really
clear way of looking at it. Thanks.
Awesome. Um but now that we have this
framework, I want to talk about the next
part which is actually the reasoning
models because we if without an example
it seems really abstract on how do you
go do this but let's talk about a little
bit about what a reasoning model is in
the first place.
Um so uh D I'm going to go to the
whiteboard really fast. I'm Oh yeah,
let's do it. Yeah, sorry. Um okay. Yeah,
because the whole point of this is less
about this content. This is more just
like setting the stage for how this
thing works. So when you're reading the
code, you get it. Because what we're
going to go do is actually make this
pipeline way more complex because like
and
like do some whiteboarding, but then
like we're going to come up with some
really interesting and complex questions
that 40 mini is just like no way it's
going to get the cipher query right.
Yeah. So let's talk a little bit about
what a reasoning model is and I think
that's going to help us understand what
they do under the hood and then we can
talk about it. So, we all know what an
uh uh well, okay, well, I'm assuming
most people that come here know what an
LLM is. It's a thing that takes in input
tokens and then spits out
Oh. Oh, interesting. inputs and arrow
choice. Uh it's a thing that takes in um
input tokens and then spits out another
only a single token at at a time. And
what we do is
uh interesting uh here I got you.
Yeah. Oh interest. Thank you. What we do
under the hood is we keep on generating
this as long as uh the token is not this
special token called eof or uh there's
some like we'll call it eof or eof which
is some like termination token. If the
token is a termination token, then we
stop and then um and then we go do
things.
Now, let's talk about what a reasoning
model does. A reasoning model does
something very very very similar to
this. Um, and I'm not going to claim
that OpenAI does this exactly, but in
theory it should be somewhat similar
where there's a special token that we
add into our So like we have an EOF
token, we actually add in another
special token that the model is allowed
to generate that looks like
this. Reason start. There's like a
couple tokens that it's allowed to do.
Reasoning
start, reasoning
N. Like this. Got it. So the model is
actually deciding when its reasoning
starts and oops I spelled reasoning
wrong. The model is to some degree
deciding what when the reasoning will
start and end and if it should reason at
all. The model may not generate the
reasoning start token. Now I as open AI
could enforce that the model generate
the reasoning start token and it has to
reason no matter what. So this first
token, in fact, my input token could
just be when I start off, like when I
have my text, I could do text plus
reasoning
start. Yeah. Have you seen I feel like
I've seen people like prompt engineering
with like either like, you know, doing
the oh, but wait inside the thinking or
doing the like Yeah. just starting the
thinking and then passing all of that
into the LLM where it's like you
actually you write the first three
sentences of thinking yourself
put it on a certain path even if you
actually write the first three sentences
of thinking just remember that the model
provider itself actually has to do the
thinking themselves the model provider
is actually the one doing the thinking
so the model provider is the one doing
thinking even if you write the thinking
text yourself you write something like
um prompt
And then you can write something like
this. You can write thinking and then
you can say blah blah blah. You'll go
write your thinking part over here.
Eventually the model provider will add a
special token
called reasoning start of some kind that
is not under your control. Oh,
interesting. Cannot make all of it
orange.
um that is not under your
control that they control that adds it
in. So technically your thinking part
looks still more like the prompt than
the actual reasoning part of the base.
Oh, I see. They don't actually let you
input the reasoning token. Exactly.
Because there's there's a token that
indicates that the reasoning starts. Now
it's possible that this is an
implementation detail and they don't
actually need the reasoning start but
they probably need some token to
indicate that the reasoning is hap that
this is a reasoning segment. It's e it's
going to be easier to train the model if
it knows that these are reasoning
chunks. Yeah. Um and then the model will
generate a bunch of text down
here. Uh and I'm going to make this
white because this is this is regular
generation. So we can think of purple as
inputs from a user. We can think of blue
as
um uh reasoning. So it's just like
regular text that the model generates.
Then the model will generate another
special piece of
text and then the model will generate
more
text, right? And this is really what a
reasoning model to some degree is doing
under the hood. And what the model is
trained to do is it's trained to
understand the meaning of these two
tokens as being like extremely useful.
If you think about what the model can do
now is in the training loop, someone can
go ahead and go train the model to go
say that uh how do I do can you do a
curve thing again? Sorry.
Yeah. uh
someone can actually train the model to
say that hey the text that lives between
reasoning start and reasoning end is
actually highly informative and you
should consider that a lot when you uh
make decisions on what text to generate
next right draws a lot of weight from
the like attention mechanism exactly and
that's a thing that the model could just
be fine-tuned to go do uh and that's
really what fundamentally what a
reasoning model is doing under the hood
and again can't really claim to know
exactly what models do. Uh it is very
hard to go predict anything about
models. Well, we've been doing parts of
this in prompts since way before it was
like baked into the model, right? You
could like ask it like, "Hey, always
think about what to do, step one, step
two, step three, and then give your
answer." And some models that are good
at instruction following might actually
just like it's not fine-tuned to trust
that stuff more, but it does you do
force it to kind of like expand out on
like what it thinks about the problem
and what needs to happen before it
actually gives you the answer. Right.
Exactly.
I think that's the whole point. So we
could go do this, but this thing just
allows the model to go have this in its
training loop. Now the problem is in the
basic training loop of what a model is
doing, it's really just trained to draw
attention from whatever it thinks is
relevant. So if you just do
this in the model generation loop, the
model is really just drawing attention
from anything that it thinks is
relevant.
I call this like standard generation or
normal generation or something. Yeah.
Yeah. The generation is the same. All
I'm saying is what the model is trying
to do is learn the difference between
tokens between these two tokens. Yeah,
have extra weight. The text, the actual
tokens in here have no special meaning.
It's just that this is a good marker for
the model
to know that everything in between has
special weight and it should be
considered a little bit more uh
logically flowing. And it might even
bias things at the bottom. I don't
really know how the model works, but it
you could reason that it could bias
things at the bottom of the reasoning
loop more than things at the top of the
reasoning loop. Right. Right. And like
the the old school way you would do this
would basically be like you would you
would call an LLM
um and you would put in your input
tokens and you would say like make a
plan like think about this thing and
tell me what you
think and then you would put that in the
LM and then it would output your like
answer which was like okay here's the
plan and then you would take that plan
and you would pass it into another like
either probably the same LLM but just
like a fresh prompt.
And then it would be like okay based on
that plan here's the answer and the plan
is something like you know do a complex
math problem or generate a bunch of code
or whatever it is right if you've used
cursor or clots on it like you've seen
it do this right exactly so like if I go
over here
um if I go over here in the above
section decks
in the wrong thinking so this is one way
to go do that where it's still standard
generation and I'm just taking advantage
of the fact that I can force the model
to generate these thinking
tokens. The only difference is instead
of the model like knowing what these
thinking tokens are and having to infer
that things between these are thinking,
I can just train it in the training loop
to know the difference.
Yeah. Otherwise, it's just taking
whatever its normal sort of like
interpretation of thinking as just what
is the meaning of that token in general,
but not as a special token. Exactly.
Exactly. That's it. So that's really all
that's happening here is the model is
somehow able to come up with
understanding what a thinking model is.
Um there's I think uh there's a question
in the chat. Yeah. Which which elems are
these reasoning tokens applicable to?
Um so these reasoning tokens are u again
this is like one possible implementation
of how reasoning could work in. Um this
there's a few other different ways that
you could implement such a thing. Um for
example the you could technically say
that reasoning start is not required. I
will only generate a reasoning end token
nothing
else. Uh you could use tool calling or
something else as an implementation
detail of how this works. But most have
something of this akin of where reason
starts. They need to have some de
demarcation in the way that the LM
generates tokens that tells you where it
ends and where it starts. Yeah. So like
the the tool calling one's really
interesting. I want to I want to pause
on that for a sec. So like you could
have a function like send email and then
you could have the parameters be
something like uh you know oh let me
make proper JSON here you know thought
process and that's a string and then you
have email content right
and so in this case if you ask the model
to output those fields in that order
it's going to tell you like oh here's
what I was thinking about and then also
here's the email. So you're kind of
forcing it to output tokens about its
thought process.
Yes. But that is very much akin to like
this option right over here. Exactly.
Yeah. Same idea. Like people have been I
think I think when function calling
first came out in like April 2023,
OpenAI had advice actually to put the
first parameter of your function to be
like thought or like thinking or like
whatever it is. And I think I've seen
like like the early lang chain function
calling loops would actually do that.
They would have it output the thought
and then they would strip that out and
print it to the console and then go run
run the function that it output.
Exactly. So, we'll talk about this in a
few seconds. Um, but just to catch
everyone else up. Um, oh, I'll leave
that there. Um, do these two different
approaches of how thinking works under
the hood makes any questions about them
so
far? I'll wait a couple seconds just to
see if people are typing them out.
Um, but if not, I think I want to move
on to the next part that I think is
going to be a lot more interesting.
Yeah. Which is going to be more along
the lines of how do we actually get
models to do thought processes kind of
akin to what you were saying? Uh, Dex.
Yeah. What one thing I'd be one thing
I'd be interested to try is like I have
a couple like top of mind like really
hard cipher queries like like text
descriptions of queries and we can try
and see if this thing can get it. We can
drop in like switch the model to a much
smarter model and see that that model
can actually figure it out and then go
back to see hey how can we pipeline boro
mini to get it to get close to the sim
same same same results. What do you
think about that? All right cool idea.
Um, so I'm going to refresh this. Let's
ask something like tell me how many
movies that Kiana
Reeves and Alan Degenerous this might be
zero are both in.
Okay. Yeah. So, I don't know if this
query is wrong or what, but I don't
know.
Um, what's another what's another one
that's hard to get right? Um, as it
turns out, it's actually very hard to
write. Um, uh, you can try the Kevin
Bacon
number's Kevin Bacon number.
Yeah.
Um, what's the definition of Kevin Bacon
number?
It's six degrees of Kevin
Bacon. He's like, um, you can just ask
it to do six degrees of play play six
degrees of Kevin
Bacon with K
Reeves. Spell it
right. Okay.
What
happened? Just say try again.
Let's see. I think this might be a back
end problem.
Uh,
okay. There you go.
So as we saw I think the most
interesting part here was that this kind
of
uh
um this kind of has an issue where we
was having a lot of variability coming
into this. So the question becomes how
could we make this better if we wanted
to? Let's swap it out to 03 reasoning 03
mini. Uh what's the 03 model that you
have? Uh I think you have 03 preview in
here.
Uh, let's use mini.
Uh, yeah, 03 mini. Okay. Oh, 03 mini. I
think that's a reasoning model. So, we
should just
Okay, that did a regen, right? Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Ah, lazy.
So one I mean firstly the model is going
to get a lot slower. We all know this
because it's going to be start
thinking. Hey sorry people
um it started to go do this and it was
able to go do something that's kind of
similar. But what will end up happening
is that this model is going to be a
little bit more um how do I describe it?
A little bit more reliable on a lot more
questions. So like for example right now
we have to add a lot more context about
what Kevin Bacon is. Just restart you
start a new question say compute the
Kevin Bacon number
for a particular actor uh for Kevin Spy
or uh yeah Kevin Spacy.
Sure. And what this model will do is
because it kind of knows what the Kevin
Bacon number is will probably produce
some of the answers of exactly what that
is along the way.
And it was all everybody's number is
two. Okay, so let's do another one. What
actors have a Kevin Bacon number five?
Good question. Now, this is going to be
a very interesting query,
but I think what I want to start playing
around with that, I'm going to ask for
Yeah. Um Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
uh, once it's done, there's also, I will
say there's a bunch of, um, if you go if
you go to the database, I'll just show
you as well. There, they have a bunch of
interesting queries with good prompts
that we could try as well. So, if you go
to connect to the server and you do play
this
thing, there we go. Uh this gives you a
bunch of HTML with like problems and
things you can do. So we can put in some
of these like really complica complex
like chicardian distance things and we
can ask it to like do this kind of
stuff. But um anyways, yeah. You want to
jump in the code? Yeah, I'm going to
request remote control for participate.
Yep. Cool. Uh let's talk about how we
could if we wanted Oops, I'm still on
drawing
mode. Let's talk about how we could if
we wanted take advantage. And I'm going
to have to do no vim mode because I'm a
flood. Uh if we want to take advantage
of GPT40 mini and somehow turn this into
a reasoning model. Well, the first thing
we could do is we could just tell the
model
um before
answering note what is useful and
particularly hard.
And we can answer this right here.
example. Okay. And before we go into
this, I kind of want to just walk
through this without having to go and do
the entire prompt the whole time. Um,
can you do me a favor and paste the
scheme? Oh, yeah. Let's get I'll get the
scheme in there for you. Uh, one second.
One second. Uh, let me just add the
hashtag. So,
cool. You can plug that. Yep.
Don't need the uh
Yeah, let me just uh real quick.
Yeah, we definitely don't need this.
Cool. So, let's look at what the prompt
ends up being like just so we can get a
good feel for this.
Um so a prompt has a massive input with
the actual schema but then at the
very at the very bottom what we do is we
add in the user's messages and after the
user's messages we tell the model what
it should be doing. We tell it that it
should be answering in one of these
schemas but then before answering I
actually wanted to go and note these
things that are particularly hard.
So, and now we'll say that the model
will actually note what things are
particularly hard and I'll start with a
cipher and then I'll go ahead and go
return it for us. So, I've in effect
I've turned this model into a reasoning
model without actually using any
reasoning under the hood. If I Well,
this is still 03 mini, right? Nope. Oh,
you switch it. Okay, nice.
Yeah. If I make this part go
away, now this part is no longer in the
problem. The model is going to output
just outputs the JSON. Exactly. So it's
going to we there's an interesting
balance that I'm able to strike which is
I can turn an existing model into a
reasoning model and make it go do things
by telling it how to go do things. Now
if I out I I think one technique that
someone mentioned in the thing is I
could tell the model to output thinking
tags
um and again this is
uh
notes and my notes and then go
answer and if I go okay
so here you can actually like experiment
which like which which thinking token
name is actually the best for for
getting good results right and you can
see that the model is actually not even
outputting this and maybe it's cuz the
word example is bad. So we can go play
around with this and it's still not
outputting this. It seems like it's a
little bit easier for the model to just
not have to think about this from like a
notes perspective and just like answer
with this as a point as a as a list and
one thing to note here is it's actually
really bene now what I could have done
is one of the and I want to comment what
I was noting earlier is I could have
added a thing into here a little bit
better.
It's called
like Oops. Yeah. Let's skip the action
first. Yeah.
Reasoning
string. I can add this into both of
these instead of doing
this. And now when I get answer, I
actually get like a little answer, a
reasoning behind what the model is
trying to do. This was the function
calling version of what we're This is
the function calling version of getting
reasoning out. And this has a couple of
benefits. But in reality, the this
actually has if I make a more
complicated query like
what
is it
reads like what is RE's most uh
reasoning number. You can see that like
this is feels a lot lot more constrained
for the model. So let's try and let's
try and not do this and instead use a
more previous thing. Um over here when
you what do you mean by constrained for
the model? You mean you're just like
forcing it to output it in a specific
format instead of like what it's used
to? This reasoning is kind of
um it's kind of like um really uh what's
the word I'm looking
for? It's really it's not how models
write. It's not like the training data
set is not going to have large blocks of
useful text in JSON objects. They're
going to be in plain text before the
JSON object. Exactly. Yeah. Like now
what we can do is now we can see this
for
example where now when it's outputting
the reasoning if I just can I make this
bigger really fast? Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. I
can also zoom out. Oh yeah, that's
great. Okay. Now if I actually look at
just the difference between these two
things to determine Kevin I need to
perform a giraffe query that connects to
reeves to the actors and movies through
this and it's trying to do this but if I
look over here it's actually able to
just output this a little bit more now
and it's able to go understand what uh
the text here is in a little bit more
well and it's cool sorry what's really
dope about this that I'm just noticing
is like it's outputting the cipher and
then it's use and it's doing that in
whatever format it wants and then it's
converting that into a JSON format. So
it's like writing cipher in the way that
like most of the training set will be
written as as like cipher in markdown
explaining [__] and then it's going to
put that into the actual structured
object. Exactly. Now you might say that
when you display a graph query to a user
you might still want to include
reasoning because there's multiple
impacts of how you can leverage using
reasoning. One is to make the model
better and this technique of outputting
the uh reasoning in the context actually
just makes the model better. Now there's
another way that we might want to do
this which is I might want to show the
user exactly what's going on behind the
scenes. So if I want to go do that then
I can add reasoning over
here description and of like the like
post post reason kind of thing. Exactly.
And what I want to hear I want to write
here is like a short
message to the user
uh
summarizing the notes.
So when I go run this I still get
reasoning as I
want and then I can give the re a
shorter version of the reasoning to uh
the end user. So I can kind of man
reasoning is now becoming a thing that I
can choose what I'm doing with rather
than a thing that I have to go do in a
specific way. So I think the blend of
what reasoning is it's very overloaded
for a lot of users.
Go ahead. It's like the the same thing
we did last week where it's like okay
you have one version of this that goes
into the embedding, one version that
goes into the LM and one version that is
read by deterministic code and those are
all three different things. And so now
you're splitting out like what's the LM
reasoning versus what's a thing that's
valuable for me to show in the UI for
the user. Exactly. And the fact that we
happen to call it all reasoning is a
totally different concept. Um it's just
like we're humans are bad at naming uh
and we're using the same name to do two
different things which normally you
wouldn't do but you can just see how
much better the reasoning is now. So in
some effect by nature of me telling the
model that I actually have to go and
display reasoning to the user I actually
got a better reasoning process right
over here as well.
Hey uh could you clarify if this is the
same as chain of thought.
Uh it's it's very similar to chain of
thought. I think it's a little bit more
free form
uh than chain of thought. I think um you
can I think when I I think when people
first introduced chain of thought it was
like a very structured approach to how
you approach a problem. It's a subset of
reasoning. Reasoning is a bigger group.
Um because reasoning doesn't necessarily
mean like I'm going to chain of thought
to me I think when the paper came out
implied that there's a sequence of
things that I will go
do here. the model happened to believe
that a sequence made
sense. But if I change my test case to
to something else where it's like uh
what it's going to read is bacon number.
It's
like how do I make
cookies and the model's actually going
to reply and the answer might be like I
actually don't want the model to reply
here. Um I can actually inject that into
the reasoning over here. Uh it's over
here before entering. Know what is hard?
Um know what is it
hard or things that indicate the user is
not
using. Let me try and find my way out of
this. trying to help the ether out
as let's add another class.
Uh,
let me get added to the return types.
Yeah.
Um, so I can go do something like this
and give an action like to the user of
like not relevant.
It's interesting that it didn't print
out all of the text though. It's just
going straight to JSON again. So I think
it's more about what the model's able to
do. So chain of thought is again very
prescribed in what it's going to go do.
Yeah. Because when it does something in
chain of thought, you're kind of forcing
it to go down that line of reasoning.
What I'm doing here, I specifically ask
the model to note what is useful and
particularly hard or things that
indicate the user is not using the
schema. But if the model feels that it's
a very direct query, then it doesn't
really have to go and go make that line.
It doesn't have to generate those
tokens. It's easier for it to just
generate the final output. And that's
where I think reasoning is a slightly
bigger superset of chain of thought.
Chain of thought is almost prescriptive.
If it doesn't do chain of thought, that
is bad because I added a chain of
thought prompt. Reasoning, I think, was
invented with this premise. And that's
what I think Openi did really amazingly.
this premise of elasticity on how much
reasoning I'm allowed to do, how much
reasoning I don't want to do. And in
this case, the model is choosing none.
And in the chain of thought world, it's
almost going to have to it it almost has
to do chain of thought. Does that answer
the question about the nuance there,
Pashant? But I think they're very very
similar.
Yeah. Uh I think it does. I mean, I'm
still trying to wrap my head around like
the model choice here. So if you had an
actual reasoning model, it treats the
prompt completely differently. So you're
not talking about that form of reasoning
here. This this reasoning here is purely
related to the model's internal thinking
process. Exactly. And if you go back to
the other thing that's the you want to
go back to the UI. No, no, not the UI,
the Excalibur.
Yeah. Yeah. So in the reasoning model
what ends up happening is a model that's
fine-tuned with reasoning is forced to
generate a reasoning start token. So it
has to out it has to do reasoning to
text and now after it does the reasoning
text then only eventually it'll output
the reasoning end token then it can
generate the regular text that I need
for the actual u
response. But in a chain of thought
world there's no such thing as reasoning
text and reasoning end. But I I almost
am chain of thought is more like this.
If the model doesn't generate thinking
text as a part of its response, it is
bad.
Reasoning all right because it doesn't
abide by my instructions of what I told
it to do. Reasoning is a little bit I
think the whole goal of reasoning is
elasticity. So the amount of tokens that
the model generates in here could be
zero, it could be 500, it could be a
thousand. And that's why OpenAI even
gives you a choice of how many reasoning
tokens you're allowed to generate,
right? How hard do you want it to think?
Right. Well, how hard do you want it to
think is one concept, but it's really
around like how many tokens are you
allowed to generate in this block? Yep.
Right. Um, and that's kind of associated
with thinking, but think about what that
does to the model. It actually it could
technically terminate
midthought because open is saying that
there's no more tokens that you can
generate after this because they can't
predict the future tokens. They can only
generate tokens up until now. It's kind
of like the conraint constraint
generation thing, right? When you force
the model to only generate tokens that
are valid JSON, you kind of you kind of
screw up with it trying to write like
whatever like in the way that it's been
trained to write things. Yeah. But the
only caveat here is that the tokens here
that it generates in the reasoning text
could have a huge
impact if I were them. Uh you could have
a huge impact in how these next tokens
are generated in a little bit more
nuanced way than it would normally be
generated. So if you if you're doing
this, there's no special things that
things in the thinking tag are getting.
It's giving no special
weight. But you could imagine that in
the training loop, the model has learned
that things between the reasoning block
are actually extra useful. So there's
one advantage to thinking models that
can't really be replicated with any
prompt engineering technique.
Now the problem with thinking models is
you will they cost a lot more because
fundamentally you are asking the model
to generate special tokens in here that
are just going to be a lot more tokens
right it's just what this whole thing
about like inference time test time
compute is just like oh if the model
generates more tokens before it actually
puts its answer in you get a better
answer uh and so people realize like oh
we don't need way smarter models we just
need them to generate more tokens before
they answer and so now it's like okay
cool So we need more GPUs and we need
more inference and we need more compute.
Exactly. And the real thought process if
you go back to our to our other thing
the code the code. Yeah. The real
thought process that I'm really having
when I make these decisions of do I just
swap out for a reasoning model or not?
It comes along the lines of the
following. when I decide to go use this
thing and swap out a reason model, what
I'm really saying is I want to spend
less time on this prompt side of it and
I wanted to mostly just work out of the
box. So, I today am willing to spend
more money. So, I spend less time
prompting and the model spends more time
prompting. It's a monthly equation and a
time equation. I want to spend less time
and and I want to spend more money in
favor of time to get a better slightly
better response. Now, you go ahead. Go
ahead. I we we have 10 minutes left and
I wanted to kind of propose just like um
a couple interesting things I' I'd be
interested to mess with um in the time
we have left. Cool. Uh go for it. Um so
I have you seen debate prompting? Have
you seen this paper? Yes. Yes. Yeah. I
was interested to see like hey if we if
we kind of take out um how do I get this
stupid annotation thing off? So like
Yeah. Okay. So, if we change this back
to like, you know, which actors have a
Kevin
Bacon number of five, which was the
thing that like the model just like
completely like floundered on the last
time. Um, and can we put in some debate
prompting where it's like we ask it like
initial
reasoning problems with initial
reasoning?
Um, you know, well, we could we could do
this in the main prompt. We don't even
have to do this in the structure.
Um, okay. Let's try this and then we'll
we'll put in the main prompt as well.
Um, or you want to do that? Yeah. Yeah,
let's play the main. It'll probably work
out a little better. Okay, cool. So this
is like initial
reasoning, problems with initial
reasoning, improved reasoning,
uh final
reasoning, and then the schema. Right?
So now there's a do you want to put this
down here or do you want to leave it
like that? That's fine. That's fine.
That's good. That's good. Okay. So
there's a actually you can run this and
I'll tell you a couple things that h
happen off the bat. So Okay. So the
first thing that you'll notice is you're
you're getting very short reasoning
responses. Yeah. So and the reason for
that is because
because we put it on bulleted list. It's
because No, no, no. It's because How do
I type? Can I Can you give me the typing
thingy? Oh yeah, there's a way to turn
off Vim mode. Hold on. Does anyone
remember which one it is? It's okay.
Just give me normal VI mode. I just need
typing. Uh I I type like a plug. Yeah,
that's fine.
You have you have other uh you have
other you want to put this in like a
markdown header just just by nature
putting it in
um putting into here. Yeah. Make a huge
difference in how things do
and we can even do something like we can
even tell it it's like I want to
generate a cipher. Oh yeah. I was going
that was the next thing I was going to
suggest is like you know one of these
headers is like propose cipher cipher
query and then problems with query and
then
and
exactly and now we can actually go do it
like over here and we can actually kind
of guide the model and the kind of
reason that we wanted to do and again
it's more about like
it's more about how we're guiding the
model really more than anything else and
it turns out if I know what kind of
approach I'm building and I'm not
actually building like
um if I'm not actually building a uh
sorry if I'm not building an an
everything chatbot like open AI and I
know building specifically a thing that
talks about cipher queries and uh rag
pipeline cypher queries on like a graph
database then I'm actually able to guide
the structure of my technique a lot more
if I don't know this then I want to go
fall back to a more free form approach
or like you know you have a router at
the top that is like oh is this about
Neo forj movies and then route it to
this prompt to handle that. Exactly.
Yes, you can do it that way as well. So
kind of build our reliability up over
time but it's all a trade-off on this
elasticity thing that I was talking
about which is like look at the very
beginning I can have one prompt that I
just throw at a mega model and it has to
do everything and go figure it out. The
problem with this onep prompt approach
that I go right where I use and oh can
you you I can just do it on the black
screen it's fine. Okay. The problem with
this one prompt approach that I will
often end up with is that my
distribution will end up looking
something like this. It's a very like
it's a very like normal distribution
that's very quite spread out. I get a
lot of variation in my responses. Now,
what Dex just suggested was I could have
a route where I build a specific prompt
that is really really good at cipher
queries and another it's going to be
trash at making cookie recipes though.
Yeah, it's going to be trash at making
cookie. Exactly. Um, where I could go
ahead and like say something that this
is like about like an intent
router and then oops uh cipher
prompt and then I can have I can still
do my my everything prompt over here.
Yeah. Everything else. Right. Exactly.
So now what what ends up happening Oh my
god, this so hard. What ends up
happening is my distribution for these
prompts will get slightly better. This
prompt should technically have a pretty
high distribution with low spread where
I can accurately get their intent
classification. Yep. And then what I aim
for is I want this prompt to have a
really really high distribution on
cipher queries and kind of perform worse
on everything else at the benefit of
outperforming on cipher queries. And
then I can actually have another one
that says that it's going to work again.
It's going to have a high it's going to
have a high spread and low accuracy on
everything else. I can slowly compose
these systems together to build a
slightly more accurate system. And this
is where I can still throw a reasoning
model at this part of my pipeline, but
have more specific reasoning on this
side of my pipeline. So I can slowly
build the system that I actually want to
build with more guidance along the way.
So it's the blend of the two. And what's
amazing about this technique is there's
nothing here that actually says I can't
actually do this with 03 mini. Like I
can kind of blend. I can let a reasoning
model do its thing and on top of that I
can also leverage non the non-reasoning
approach to go ahead and think about
this as well and once it's done it will
go do it. I wish we thinking tokens. We
really should.
Um yes I would like that too if you'll
spit out the thinking tokens. Yeah, if
you do the curl, you can see both. And
thinking tokens come, it's so crazy
because like the thinking tokens just
get spewed out raw and then it spits out
JSON at the end, which is actually kind
of bambly when you think about it. Yeah.
Um I want to try one more thing um in
the five minutes we have left on the
clock and then we can um hold for time
for questions at the end. Does that
work? Let's do it. Um I want to take
these three things and uh put them in
the response.
um do it.
So, and then I want to spit them out to
the user in the UI because like this
becomes kind of a magical kind of AI app
building experience as
well. Um so,
uh and just be like a short summary of
initial message, a shorter a short
summary to display to the user.
Yeah, it's specific that we want to talk
about displaying to the user because we
don't want to bias the actual generation
token that's going to go generate.
Um, cool. Um, sick. And then in our
actual server code, like the fact that
we have kind of built this agent at
hawk, we can do some really interesting
things and like kind of take the outputs
of our fancy prompting and throw it
through everything else. Um, I added
another one which is called not
relevant. Can you delete that? That's
why this uh Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Um on line 39. Yeah. We'll just get rid
of this.
Yep. Chat doesn't work. That's why.
Yeah. Um I love that JavaScript. I'm
actually going to
um cool. and then completion the send a
reasoning event. Yeah.
And then on the front end we can
actually try to display this
um ah where is our app app.ts page app.
Yeah components. Here we go. Um,
nice. This is going to be a little bit
janky, but let's see. Let's see how this
looks.
Um, or this is live coding. I've never
tried this before. Oh, you're on 03
Mini. Can you get Oh, whatever. Uh,
sure. Love the GT40 mini so it's faster.
Yeah, let's go to 40 mini. I don't have
time. No, we don't have time for that
crap. Yeah.
[Music]
Um, let's go
here. Let's
go. Cool. Um,
um, do a simple one and then we'll do a
really hard one. Yeah.
It didn't show our
reasoning. This is the fun part of live
coding.
Um, did you see what's going on there?
Um, you might have to restart the app.
Just restart the app really fast.
Also, this is just absolutely wrong. Um,
okay.
How many movies is
uh Patrick sees and we'll start with a
simple one.
Um do you render the reasoning object?
Uh I think we're trying to. Let's see.
It's also not getting added to the
messages stream here.
Okay. Um, you should just see on the
back end as you're setting it
up. Okay, so this definitely came
out.
Um, we we'll time box this to like two
more minutes. If we can't get it
working, we'll we'll flip to questions
or people want to start asking
answering. Well, let's see if we can get
this working.
You go to send events.
No, this one is working. And then what's
the event name that you sent it as? Uh
reasoning.
Yeah. And then just double check that
you're actually receiving it as that
event in your thing.
So event reasoning event graph query.
Okay, so we did get a reasoning event.
It's just like a UI bug. Yeah. Oh, see
Reasoning
message. Um,
oh, you have to set messages.
Go up to the top and you just miss one
line after that. After reasoning
message, just enter. Oh, yeah. Here we
go. Great. There you go.
Uh, it didn't do the query. It won't do
it again because it has the answer.
Yeah. uh in the message context. Yeah.
Yeah. There we go. So, you could style
this however you wanted. Um
um uh I'd love for questions that people
have if they want to type into reason
models. Otherwise, I have a few other
notes that I think might be worth it to
talk about, but uh questions first.
I think I posted mine which is like what
are the like ideas we can like condense
from all of this because I know we had
like things thrown in different
directions but what would you say is the
biggest takeaway? I think the biggest
takeaway is really about time management
of your engineering team is the biggest
thing that I think about which is if you
really want to ship something really
really fast just throw an 03 model let
it do its reasoning and you basically
save time and you get the generation you
want out on average this will be better
just like using GPT40 on average will be
better than GP40 mini on average a
reasoning model will have a slightly
better
curve then of like like if I talk about
accuracy versus varian A reasoning model
will just be slightly less like this
will if this is 040
uh then a reasoning model will be
slightly le slightly better uh than than
40. Oh yes, thank you. That's I'll
remove that for posterity. Um just I
want it to be in the in the whiteboard
for when we do the recap. I'll draw it
on here. Um the reason model will
basically just be like slightly um
slightly better like the reason like
this. So the correlary here is like if
you need performance and speed and
things like this, then you can go into
engineering your own version of this.
Right. Exactly. Then Exactly. So if you
need better speed, you need better
performance, you need better choice,
then you can go ahead and go down the
direction of actually picking the
reasoning model of your choice. And or
like if you need to run models on prem
and you can't run deepseeek R1 or
whatever and you can only run little
llama models because you're at the edge
or something. Exactly. And then the
other thing you want to note is that
like De said, not every model will
support reasoning. So this is how you
can leverage almost any model to go get
reasoning out of it. Um, and really
spending a little bit of time on what
the reasoning that you want the model to
generate is specifically with like the
guided prompts that we showed earlier
can improve your accuracy of evening
reasoning models because free form
reasoning as good as it is just going to
be worse than guided reasoning if you
know the domain you're operating in.
Yeah. Right. So like if and that's the
example of like asking it to actually
like hey when you're reasoning output a
cipher query and then review it and then
output another one like there's no way
to prompt a thinking model to do this
other than like by asking it to do this
basically like it's not going to come up
with this structure probably. Yeah. And
this structure might be good it might be
bad. Obviously this is going to make it
way worse for generating cookie recipes.
Um, so don't do that. Uh, if you're if
you need it to generate cookie recipes
and this, but if you know that it
doesn't have to do this, then it can um
it can do something kind of I think you
can get way better results.
Yeah. See, it's like just gave up and
said I can't do cookies because of how
like intense its prompt was.
Dex and Weber, I have a question here.
So I understand for
the for the normal models we have done
some kind of prompt engineering where it
is where we are asking it to reason over
create a cipher then reason over it. Is
it the same thing like splitting it into
two maybe actor and checker kind of
thing? One is acting then creating a
loop between these two and refining it.
Is that same or what is the difference?
The only thing network curves that's a
slightly different thing. Um because the
way that that is working is
um I'm going to go in solid draw and
just draw what that ends up looking
like. D I'm going to draw at the bottom.
Yep. I'm here. I'm following you. Um so
what that ends up looking like is this.
So you're going to have a model go
generate some let's say you have like
some question by a
user. I don't know why it's green. Um a
user will ask a question. Then what
you're doing is you're having the model
go generate some um some
response. Then what you're doing is
you're having another user then you're
having another model like do like do
like like a
checker response. And this is like the
actor response. This is what you're
talking about. This is like LM is judge,
right? It's like, hey, review the
question and the answer and see if it
makes sense kind of thing, right? And
then you kind of do this and like an
iteration loop. Now, the thing that
people don't realize when they do this
is that your costs here are actually
exponential. So, the first time you call
the active response, your cost is just a
question. When in order to generate the
uh and I'll make this red so it's a
little bit more clear. In order to
generate the checker response, your cost
is the question plus the
checker plus uh uh plus the sorry
question plus the actor. Yep. In order
to generate this next one, it's question
plus act
actor plus checker again. So just to do
like um just to do like a two-step
process, you're passing the question
three times, you're passing the actor
twice.
So your costs boil up exponentially
really fast with this approach and if
you're able to do it in line in the same
prompt now your cost is basically just
once for the question the actor checker
actor response like the thing Dex showed
in the in the code that he generated
with the cipher query that is a single
cost for all these things but isn't
sorry isn't every token here like every
every token that it's emitting you're
still reprocessing the entire thing. So
is this just like a context caching kind
of thing we're taking advantage of
models? Yeah, there's an optimization
loop that allows them to not price you
for that every single time, right?
You're not rerunning them into a new
request. You're just open pricing you is
only for the new tokens that you're
generating. If you go back to the other
thing, yeah, now OpenAI is pricing you
in a way where it's like the question is
being priced three different times here
because they're all separate requests to
an LLM and they're treated as separate
and it's like re reloading all the Yeah.
Okay. Exactly. Does that make sense uh
for the person that asked the question?
Yeah. Yep. It does. Perfect. So, there's
a benefit of basically cost, accuracy,
and latency. In general, with this loop,
you can get a little bit more control,
but your cost will be a lot more and
your latency will be a lot more. If
you're able to do it in a single system,
you might as well.
Great question. I love that question. I
hadn't thought about it this way, but
that makes a ton of sense. Um, other
other key other question also vibe. Does
that does this capture all the key
takeaways? like basically like time
management versus co cost management and
like being able to basically do really
specific guided reasoning better than a
generic model that's just trying to like
spew a lot of nonsense before it
answers. Yeah. And then one thing to
note remember is that I showed that you
can always use the combination of a
reasoning model with guided reasoning as
well.
We have one more question over here.
Um while asking LLM I can be wrong about
many names. Sorry I'm I'm I'm not into
movies. I don't know any of the names
but I saw you writing caves or something
reenu keys or some something like that.
U if it if it's a wrong typing from the
user do we actually go and check or is
it like LLM correcting on behalf of us
first and then generating cipher? How is
it working? There's a really interesting
blog post that I want to write about
this which is how LM are just amazing
spell checkers. Um
oftentime if you go back to the code I
think it's just easier to show in a
demo.
I understood that point I guess but uh
think of it in in con uh in perspective
of organizational data for example
employee database right LM has no idea
about it. So if I create a knowledge
base let's say skill database of every
employee and I'm I'm just asking that uh
graph to give me answer about how many
are you know skilled on
BML right and then I say someone uh I
give it a I give it a name basically and
I want to get back all the skills of
that particular employee from the graph.
So how does it work? Can you go to the
can you go to the
uh codebase? I want to show a couple
examples because I think it's going to
be easier to talk about this with code
because I think what is how can I get
the model to reason about something in
the case of it like being really unique.
So it turns out because LM are really
really good spell checkers. They will
they will not abide by you. And I'm
going to use like very simple examples
to make this a point of how you could go
do this. So let's say I'm I'm looking at
a resume thing. I spelled name wrong.
it is going to be virtually impossible
for me to get the model to spit out
NAE. It is going to be really, really,
really hard. So, if an employes name
just has a totally different misspelling
of it and it never works, it is going to
be really, really, really hard for me to
guide the model in that direction,
right? Um, so how would I actually go do
this? It turns out the only real way to
go do this is you will have to give the
model a name that it can output and then
convert it post programmatically into
the name that actually generates. So if
you a model is just a statistical
distribution of
tokens. So if an if a thing is just
statistically super super super super
unlikely to be the thing that you want
it to be then you have to fall back
towards techniques like constraint
generation. you have to fall back
towards techniques like aliasing where I
let the model see the content that I
want to go see it and then that's the
only real way to navigate that scenario.
In the case of names, it's a little bit
more interesting because
like so like I just wrote my name
without any
vowels or actually I'll do this. My last
name is pretty
popular and like we'll just see what the
model thinks when I go and go output
name.
It might output my name directly. But if
I use a slightly worse
model, see if I can get to or let me
try. Yeah, there you go. You got it. It
No, it still output the name correctly.
So I want I want I want to show like a
slightly worse model like doing dumb
things with
like Mitch.
Dom
Smith. So I
want
smit correct.
Yeah. Jithgmail.com. And I'll go run
this. So in this it's actually doing it
correctly. But you can imagine a much
dumber model actually just outputting
John instead of JHN. And the only real
thing you can do in this scenario is
actually in your codebase just write
another system that just checks and says
that the name is actually in one of the
names that you provided. And if it
isn't, then I make a smaller query that
says what is the exact name from this
list of names that makes sense and
actually uh have the model go and
generate one of those as a corrective
measure because in case the model
doesn't output something that's actually
in your employee database, then you can
go double check that. That would be the
approach that I would take in this
approach. And like no amount of
reasoning model or something else can go
fix this because models are just
predictive systems and they will at some
point be wrong and you have to build
systems on top of it to make it correct
not just let it go out and hope that it
is
correct. Does that answer the question
on above?
Yes. Yes, I think it does. One one more
question here. So I I see a lot of
things happening on grounding LLM using
graph and database and especially giving
your ontologies and business related or
do domain specific things to it. For
example, I I only have lawyer and super
lawyer that kind of stuff and then
letting it decide whether someone is
reporting to some other person because
these two people are having different
descriptions on their job post such a
was was there originally a plan to
discuss this point as well use to ground
LM in this call or no? No, I don't think
we were going to talk about necessarily
graph databases or something here. What
we really wanted to go do is graph
databases are a complex type of query.
So, we just wanted to use that to show
off like different reasoning techniques
that you could use for graph databases.
I'm probably not the best expert. I
don't know about that, but like I know
I'm not the best expert on like graph
databases and like all the different
applications of them. Um, yeah, the idea
here is I think like for complex things
that reasoning models are really good at
like coding and like writing queries and
doing these structured things. um that
there's all these techniques you can use
and so the the using the graph database
was more of like here's an example of a
thing that reasoning models tend to be
better at how do we get reasoning model
level performance out of a tiny model.
Yes. Uh if you if I think if you join
the B boundary discord and ask Pashant
he has a lot of knowledge about graph
databases.
Thanks. Yeah, happy to bounce ideas. I'm
right here on the call but I I'm on BAM
and Discord as well.
Um, other questions from anyone else
that they might want to have answered
while we're here. Actually, I I have a
question Weber. So, just to follow up
with this original question above hand.
So, I think I had the same thought when
he asked that, which is let's say you
had a graph database of uh employees and
their skills and BAML was one of those
skills and then you issue a query saying
give me all the employees who have the
skill BAML but you misspell BAML as BA B
A L M. Yeah. Now LLMs will that's a
classic case where the misspelling is a
correct term and the correct spelling is
the is the misunderstood term right so
in that situation your your LLM is going
to actually search for bum and it's
going to fail because you're going to
get an empty response from that sit from
the database t right this would be like
if we misspelled ke ree name right
search for exist yeah so so the point is
I notic in the implementation that you
you have decks it's just giving you
empty results all the time in an
infinite loop it's just not doing
anything after the empty result So the
right way to handle this would be
something like you have a fallback where
if you don't get like this uh if you get
an empty result you don't assume that
the information does not exist you try
the query in a different form uh in a
way that the you at least try from a
different perspective because the issue
is that you don't know whether the
answer is wrong missing or in uh correct
like there's three possibilities right
exactly so there's no real way for you
to know that unless you potentially like
especially when you have an empty result
you don't know whether it's wrong or
missing
Yeah. So you could come here and check
and say like if if the result is empty,
you can instead push something into the
context that is like you did. Beautiful
example. Yeah. Reb had a really good
example of this in the Neo Forj stream
that he did with the Neo Forj people. Uh
that's something I highly recommend
whoever's on this call, please go and
watch that one because uh the way you
handle the retry and you know preventing
failure modes when you have misspellings
or typos or whatever other minor issues,
those are different ways to think about
it.
Oh, let me try again. Yeah, just making
an assistant message.
And now you're kind of done.
So, we can actually add like a special
thing into here that adds that in for
the user that says we actually forcibly
add this into the context where we say
something like, oh, the query didn't
result return any results. Perhaps it's
wrong. W wrong or
misspelled.
Uh should we ask the user for more?
Right. You're injecting thoughts
for
more information there. Yeah. This is
this is kind of what you Yeah. had
before. This is a good one. And now what
can happen is I'm actually injecting
stuff into the context that comes again
from me from all of us kind of knowing
upfront that this is a this is a
contextual application built around
talking to a graph database and that
these kinds of things where it's
empty might
uh might not not for sure might uh be
wrong. But you can't do this generically
if that makes sense.
Yep. Makes total sense. Cool. You can
Yeah.
Um cool. Super interesting. What What
else we got?
Awesome. Um I think that's it for this
time. Uh next week we're going to have a
really really fun conversation about a
topic that I am personally really
excited about. Um, you have a thing
available on under on there uh text.
Okay, I'll pull it up. Oh, you want
Yeah. You want to pull up the uh the
card? Yeah. Which is I think
um or are you pulling up? I can pull it
up. Yeah, go for it. Which I think is
going to be something that is really
relevant to a lot of people as we go
forward, which is people talk a lot
about like fine-tuning and how we can go
do this. Um, this one is going to be a
lot more conceptual on how we can
actually leverage human feedback and how
we have to collect data in a way for our
AI pipelines so we can fix them with rag
versus fine-tuning.
That's that's in two weeks, I think.
Unless we're switching the schedule
around. Oh, sorry. No, no, sorry. Yes,
that's the last one. Oh, I I was I was
blown away. We're gonna talk about code
generation. I think code generation will
be a really fun one. Yeah, I agree. Um,
but um excited to see you all again.
Thank you all for joining. Uh, see you
again next Tuesday. Yeah. Thanks y'all.
This was super fun.
Fun.